the call of home is strong and it has
sustained those who've managed to
survive the virus it helped truth
Charita a nurse from Zimbabwe who
contracted Kovac while working at a
hospital in Northamptonshire she was
greeted by family and friends on her
homecoming their feelings transformed
into song just 20 or so miles away
another nurse from Zimbabwe was brought
back to the house Musa and Jubilee Lowe
spent three weeks in hospital and his
wife Deborah struggled to find the right
words
[Applause]
[Applause]
according to Zimbabwean embassy
officials at least 37 Zimbabweans have
died in Britain during the pandemic the
vast majority frontline health workers
were told it's an extraordinary figure
from a relatively small immigrant
community they come to Britain to care
for the sick and alleviate chronic staff
shortages at the country's hospitals
clinics and care homes in fact 13% of
NHS staff in England have come from
abroad
Zimbabwean root endow MOOC Watson Jarrah
arrived in 2002 and worked as an NHS
administrator in Staffordshire but she
died in April two weeks after
contracting the
iris her funeral was live streamed on
the internet for the family back at home
she was the eldest daughter of mine and
you know we were just like sisters she
we used to talk about this and that
didn't that so all that is gone root
endow supported her mother and her
extended family in the Zimbabwean
capital her re working additional shifts
to send money home
I'm just helpless now was routine was so
good she was looking after its children
making sure they get a good education in
the here the days she would give me some
money what she knew I'd retired now all
that is shattered it's a difficult time
for the family
pretend Oh has left a daughter called
chiesa
in the UK she's currently being cared
for by friends I feel like how she
always found away you through I feel
like I can always find a way through any
challenge
and it's a difficult time for the
Zimbabwean community welcome to the
rumba sideshow Rubens i bovitz away
bhaiyya hosts a popular chat show on
social media and she's been exploring
the collective trauma felt by uk-based
Zimbabweans she never really feel safe
she thinks nursing staff may have gone
to work when they were sick and should
have stayed home some continued working
when they were not feeling well because
they were not sure whether they had it
or not and I think Zimbabweans we are a
nation of very hard workers we we we
work hard when you know real hard
workers and it's it's it's difficult to
actually stop people from working it's
the fear perhaps of of what will happen
to us in Dover one GP has become
seriously alarmed
dr. Brighton Cherica is collecting
testimony from thousands of Zimbabweans
and other bay more a minority ethnic
health staff in the UK and he's
concerned about the people employed by
private agencies the people are working
these aliens companies mostly been
people so thus were being unfairly
allocated in corporate walls so it means
that you are coming to only cover those
areas which are high risk so that puts
again staff that would been people at
higher risk because they are being
allocated in those ships those are the
ships we just make left overs in
Northampton Bishop and Jubilee Lowe has
gone back to work at the local hospital
and says he feels fine but he's a member
of a community that's paid a terrible
price during the pandemic and they want
to know why they're so vulnerable John
Sparkes Sky News